let's read this first story and talk
about weird whatever with florida the
daily mail reports florida's governor
ron desantis is applauded by children as
he officially strips disney of its 55
year old special tax and land privileges
after biden slammed ugly gop for going
after mickey i kind of feel like uh this
country is pretty much falling apart uh
i will say
it's funny that they bring in a bunch of
kids they have a photo of this they had
a photo here we go look at this they
have like you know
crt is is in a circle with a line
through it is there a word for that
crt no no no when they put a circle with
a line through it
crossing something out or whatever but
they brought a bunch of kids and they're
all clapping and cheering i think that's
i think that's funny i like what he's
doing though i like what uh what rhonda
santa is doing and we can see that
disney continues to drop in its stock
prices so i'll just i'll just start off
by saying this i went to there's a
protest in disneyland that i went to oh
no no that was disney world
that's the one in florida
disney world's in florida world yeah the
other one's in anaheim okay so i was at
disneyland uh there was a protest for
black lives matter i i don't think it
was necessarily black lives matter but
was the same issues
and the police did everything in their
power to protect disney and they were on
horseback with bokken you know boken are
a wooden sword yeah wooden swords and it
was like the weirdest thing but what
people noticed was that they weren't
protecting any of the homes they were
protecting they were blocking off the
roads to disney and these were guys who
are like wearing full like camo decked
out military gear riding on the side of
suvs with with long guns is just the
craziest thing
isn't it weird though how the democrats
are now like like on the side of the big
corporate entity disney
so yes it is are they or are they just
against desantis i can't get a read on
this no they're they're they they're an
amorphous blob
there's no i don't i don't they're not
for against anything they're just they
just hate you
right so it's like geez guys take it
easy well no but they do i mean if if
there's something that
i don't know civil libertarians and
conservatives are interested in they're
just gonna be like well we hate that and
so if that means they're gonna side with
tax cuts for massive multinational
corporations apparently that's what's
happening well but uh you know uh this
is why i think it's it's great to have
you here tina cause i'm curious with
everything we've been seeing uh over the
past several years with the rioting with
the political partisanship with now
children clapping and cheering for this
stuff with with critical race theory in
schools i'm wondering if you have ever
seen it this bad no
i mean i haven't
we were talking earlier about
my sort of coming of age which was i was
in
college in 1969 as a freshman in
washington
at georgetown and it was you know the
height of the vietnam war it was civil
rights it was women's rights
and
i don't know if i was more naive but i
was certainly way more clear about my
world than i am now and i'm 70.
shouldn't i be more clear about my world
now
with age and
theoretically wisdom
um
i don't know what that means
uh but do you mean by clear like you
don't know what's going on i don't know
where i don't know how to think about a
lot of things
anymore because i don't
i i'm very mistrustful of pretty much
everything i hear
and
we were talking earlier about just about
newscasters in my
day and you know it was walter cronkite
and um
chet huntley and david brinkley and
edward r murrow and you respected those
men and you didn't really know much
about them
except
the pitch of their voice when you knew
when something was serious you know if
i'm sure you've all seen the clip of
walter cronkite taking his glasses off
when he announced jfk
had been assassinated it was a
i don't know things were
it's almost like
things were serious then
and
everything's made to be serious now yeah
i don't know if that's the right way to
put it but yeah
um
i i don't know if things are better or
worse we were talking lydia and i
earlier about our my mother saying you
know the world has always been bad yeah
so
i wonder though like how do you how do
you know you can trust those men like
walter cronkite then yeah they smoked
cigarettes well you didn't yeah exactly
that so did my father
yeah
um
you didn't think about it
there wasn't a question of trust it was
there were three networks
there were very many fewer platforms for
information
and you didn't hear about as many things
at the same time
and it was i don't know
it was just a little easier possible
they were lying
well it's that's also possible gulf of
tonkin yeah gulf of tonkin exactly well
there was a lot of that i mean they have
pick the cia
there was always a
subterranean text that
you'd well you didn't question it i
think is also
we also talked about in the past how at
that time the young people were part of
the counter culture which was counter
culture and now you know with a lot of
the protests that happened over the last
two years you have like corporations on
board with those and like using it to
prove that they're virtuous
i went to a skate park and i saw black
lives matter tagged
and then i just started laughing and
they're like kids hanging out and i was
like which one of you kids tagged the
corporate slogan on the on the skate
ramp
okay it's but they don't care
you know they're gonna they're gonna
look at me and they're like you're an
old man you don't get it and i'll be
like yeah when i was your age we we we
rebelled against authority you know we
tried to find our own way but you guys
are just stooges they're just like well
walmart told me to write it so i did
it's like all right good for you i guess
what strikes me is the watergate scandal
when that popped i mean that was like
the end of nixon's his campaign at the
time i believe and correct me if i'm
wrong what i mean he he was didn't you
didn't he he resigned right that was the
end of his presidency
he resigned yeah before because you're
spying on the democrats during the
campaign and then when they found out
when hillary's emails popped and they
just like spying on bernie's campaign is
that right she was spying they were
supposed to be trump on trump's campaign
yeah uh where's the outrage where's the
sandbag bernie's um yeah
him being jewish and using it against
him and stuff in the emails like how is
this not causing a watergate level
landslide of of reprisal
because there's a military industrial
complex and now the the spy network it's
like they've been trying to build this
technocracy since 1913 the rockefeller
you know the military industry the uh
basically the federal reserve was the
first the beginning of it with
uh what's his name
uh woodrow wilson and now they have the
technology in place to actually spy with
the patriot act and things like that and
so they're like just they don't even
care anymore they're just trying to take
control of everything it's so gross have
you been following the critical race
theory stuff in the news
as much as i
as much as it has sustained my interest
which is none none
well i shouldn't put it that way um
no comment
you know because i i don't know if you
wanted to talk about the comparison
between feminism then and feminism today
well
i wouldn't feminism and critical race
theory
critical theory right yeah so so what
we're seeing now uh started with what's
called intersectional feminism which is
a tenet of critical race theory so
it starts with second wave feminism
which i believe is what like the 60s 70s
first wave was like suffragettes
third wave i think was what was what we
saw in the 2000s and now
so this is all just considered to be
waves of feminism
so what happens is
third wave feminism started asking these
questions about privilege
intersectionality and race
and so what started very much with
if you're a woman a biological female
then you know you have certain rights
and things you're not granted access to
so those rights are you know hard are
fought for and uh it's like workplace
pay you know pay parity things like that
and then you get into the late 2000s
early 2010s and feminism all of a sudden
starts adopting what's called
intersectionality which is what is i
don't know i don't know what that is
what is intersectionality
intersectionality is that sorry
a woman faces a certain kind of
discrimination
so do what everybody does and so
intersectionality says the
discrimination faced by a woman is
different than the discrimination faced
by a black woman why because at the
intersection of race and feminism there
is something unique
that is experienced only by black women
so specifically there is the trope of
the angry black woman
so when someone is being sexist towards
a black woman there's an element of race
comprised within it
okay from there
which is so so intersectional is uh
intersectionality is a component of
critical race theory okay i it's way too
i look at it a lot more simply i think
you know certain if you want to talk
about women
certain women have it harder than other
women and i think probably black women
do generally you know across the board
women who are poor women who are raising
children by themselves
you know women
it some people have it easier some women
have it easier than other women i can't
i can't relate to
i don't get it the intersectionality
hole i don't know it's a way of talking
about it in a complicated in a
complicated it's a way of making sense
of the world and you know it's like a
way of
basically identifying
the reasons for
why people face struggles and why you
know
certain people have to overcome more but
at the same time like just those
exterior immutable traits
really don't have anything to do with
people's individual situations um in
terms of like
what they might be born into that's
beyond that you know it puts you in a
box effectively the result is that these
schools are now telling white kids that
they're inherently bad right
you know and they're saying white white
white is bad and whiteness is evil and
so now you have kids who are coming home
and telling their parents their parents
are revolting and now you're getting
republicans winning in a bunch of
different states so it seems like
you know you see bill maher wake up to
this kind of stuff he starts talking
about how the democrats are basically
destroying themselves by isolating and
fracturing their their their voting
blocks well isn't this also it's kind of
an extension of um
erasing
culture in a way i mean it's all sort of
the same it's
trying to make a new reality out of
something that was not
a pleasant reality is that
reinterpreting our past yeah like this
is a really simple way to put it i i
don't watch the news a lot anymore
and i watch tmc or tcm it's the movie
channel
and it's really well done it's all the
old movies it's the movies i grew up
with that my mother you know knew all
the word songs
to the word the words to all the songs
to
and they have adapted this position of
you know there's this whole conversation
about
say gone with the wind as an example
and
just erasing it because it represented
um
a bad thing
about you know whites and slavery
but there's no point in erasing
any of it let's face what it was and
move on and is it isn't it a similar
kind of
conversation well now uh
you know california just tried repealing
their civil rights provision from their
constitution
the the democrats in california wanted
to repeal
the uh anti-discrimination provision
which prevented discrimination the basis
of race
and their argument was we need to
discriminate on the basis of race to
help minorities and and so you know my
response there is like to go back in
time yeah to you know the pre-1960s
as some as some like you think it was
better when that's how the laws were
structured but that's what they're doing
that's the democrats that are doing that
it's not the republicans and then it's a
question of how far you go back in time
because oh you know um
if you go back on a long enough timeline
like for example the the irish were
being enslaved by the hundreds of
thousands per year in baghdad in the
800s and at that time the arabs were the
dominant culture in the world the irish
yeah the irish were getting dragged over
to basically slave markets all over the
world by the vikings and stuff like that
they just come in grab them and you know
and the british are in baghdad
yeah and the slavs which is where slave
comes from and the italians
yeah yeah man people were the only
vikings you have italian privilege all
right the vikings would go down the
rhine they sacked paris they were
everywhere they were in the
mediterranean that was nuts now look at
norway and they built castles in sweden
and they couldn't penetrate the castles
that's crazy though right because when
you look at
the the nordic countries they're very
effeminate
anymore yeah so a lot of people are
wondering like wow this they used to be
particularly barbaric you know seriously
going around stealing people and now
they're all very much like equality and
you know fair wages it's like all right
well and that's yeah that's the other
problem with applying like immutable you
know characteristics to cultures and
stuff like that like oh because you're
born like this then you're because
you're like this you're going to face
this challenge you know because you yeah
actually i think if you look at the
nordic countries it's a really good
example for why we should not blame a
group of people for the sins of their
past yeah to say like you know right now
that's the big thing with critical race
theory is that white people are evil
settler colonialism is wrong and english
is an oppressive language and it's like
i don't know if the uh
you know the vikings can figure things
out and become
you know i don't know what equitable and
peaceful or whatever why are you going
to blame them for what other people did
right
that's true and i mean
that's really the question is like what
is um you know america is a very like
young country and i think that a lot of
times our collective understanding of
culture in history is
very much shorter than like in europe
for example like if you next to your
school you have a cathedral from the
1200s you have a tendency to like think
of things on a longer timeline and so
yeah we have this very kind of like it's
our understanding of like the history of
progressivism is like three generations
long and you know it's like
i think that that neglects to realize if
you think back a little bit further then
you realized more progress than you
think has been made thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there